now i know this might be hard to believe
but certain people once they start
carbs they cannot stop
so recently i had a person who reached
out and wanted some help because they
were
slightly addicted to carbs they wanted
to start keto
but they had this addiction how do they
go about it
so i decided to create a video for this
person all right we've been trained
since birth to consume sugar
okay it's in baby food it's in all of
our foods
and uh you know go trick-or-treating and
you get all this candy and
every holiday and cookies etc etc and
what happens inside our body
every time we do this is we start to
develop um
an addiction um and that involves
two neurotransmitters one is dopamine
which is involved with
pleasure sensation and then we have
serotonin which is involved with the
happiness sensation now i used to have
an addiction i mean a
periodic craving for ben and jerry's ice
cream
i got caught up in this uh eating a pint
every night before i went to bed type
situation
over i would say a year i would be
obsessed about it i would be thinking
about it all day long
and eventually if i didn't consume it i
had this pressure or stress build up
that may be physically uncomfortable but
as soon as i started consuming
this delicious ice cream i felt
satisfied happy i felt like i was
surviving
i could finally breathe again for about
about a minute now of course this was
artificially
making me satisfied happy and
feeling like i was surviving when i
actually was feeling very miserable the
rest of the day
and not really surviving health-wise
so what you have to realize is that
every time you give in to this craving
you're going to get more cravings over
time it's going to happen it's going to
become stronger and stronger
over time and it's very interesting to
me that
your body can get into a state
physically where it demands
this sugar this addiction is real
and it will literally control you to a
point where
you're completely out of control so what
can you do at this point
number one you need to stop eating
completely you need to start fasting
immediately because what's gonna happen
instead of eating food
you're gonna eat no food and your body
is gonna have to switch over there's
gonna be a little uncomfortable
transition period but it won't be too
bad
or your body will start to switch to
ketosis and then when you start
burning fat for fuel your brain
actually starts to heal and reset
because the receptors for these
neurotransmitters are so messed up
they need to be reset the absolute best
way to do it is simply
start fasting i would recommend
minimally 24 hours to
48 hours and if you can actually do
exercise
light exercise walking that would be
even better because you can burn off
that
sugar that you just consumed so just get
it out of the system
get your body into ketosis and then your
brain
will feel better the interesting thing
about the brain is that if
given the choice the brain will prefer
ketones
over sugar any day it's very therapeutic
and as soon as that happens you start to
shift to be more in control
over this addiction all right
number three you have to be very careful
to avoid the triggers
get all the junk food out of the house
including those chips that you have
up in the cupboard that you've been
hiding make it difficult for you to get
this
junk food especially late at night when
you're kind of bored so many people at
night
they're not even hungry they're just
going through the cupboards looking for
something
they don't even know what they're
looking for but maybe something salty
and crunchy maybe something sweet
but you need to get the junk out of your
house
very important when you're fasting
don't read cookbooks okay especially for
desserts
you want to avoid any type of
trigger including pictures of recipes or
desserts
because dopamine is all about
anticipating pleasure
as soon as you eat this food
you don't continue to increase dopamine
dopamine is kind of a
precursor to actual eating it so
as soon as you look at a picture or
smell
food you instantly start increasing the
dopamine and that is going to create
a controlling factor over your body
let's say for example you're driving
your bike down your neighborhood
and it's dinner time and you can smell
spaghetti cooking in the
from someone's house that would be bad
don't do that
so smells are very powerful kentucky
fried chicken they pump out all these
different smells
so they can lure you into that facility
avoid any and all environments
that can tempt you and lastly b vitamins
are
are crucial vitamin b1
will completely handle this right here
okay so use that through nutritional
yeast
to help curb your
addictions i'm sorry your cravings
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can
tolerate and resist
your environment much better by
strengthening
your own immune system i put a link down
in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today